[Musik]
wir von der trendforschung bayern sind
stolz ihnen den neuesten fast food
kracher präsentieren zu dürfen
vergessen sie ab sofort zu schoko den
thunfisch rap mit wasabi mayonnaise oder
den räucherlachs regel mit senf deal
cremen alles schnee von gestern
nach fünfjährigen verbraucherstudien an
über 20.000 probanden haben wir ein
produkt für sie entwickelt das nicht nur
besonders nahrhaft und lecker ist
sondern zudem auch das zukünftige
essverhalten revolutionieren wird das
forscht brot
leck mich doch schmeckt ist gut nicht
wahr und das tollste sie können das
wurstbrot auch ganz einfach zu hause
selbst erstellen
zum mond film kommen oder wie
ernst nehmen sie einfach eine scheibe
brot und eine scheibe brust und jetzt
und jetzt einfach nur die scheibe wurst
auf die scheibe brot legen
[Musik]
das ist ja wahnsinn lassen auch sie sich
begeistern von neuen trend am snack
himmel die ihm wurscht brot
[Applaus]
[Musik]